did you know that doctor strange had a
wife marvel comics fans know all about
her but casual mcu fans were likely
confused by all the hype about a certain
cameo and multiverse of madness keep
watching to learn all about strange's
powerful spouse warning spoilers for the
mid-credit scene in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness ahead
when the doctor strange film was
released in 2016 many fans were
disappointed to find one major character
conspicuously missing from the story
introduced in strange tales number 126
back in 1964 the sorceress known as clea
has long been one of steven strange's
most prominent supporting characters a
magical user whose power and stature
rival doctor strange himself she's
appeared as the sorcerer supreme's
partner been the sorcerer supreme
herself and is certainly no minor
background character though she's rarely
thought of as one of marvel's premiere
heroes she's a key member of the
sorcerer's supreme's inner circle and
has been featured alongside him outside
of the comics too appearing in video
games animated appearances and toys
she's even been seen on screen in live
action twice now believe it or not so
what's clea's story clea is not of
earthly origin despite her human
appearance while stephen strange hails
from new york city clia is the product
of an entirely separate dimension the
dark dimension
it's a place beyond time
home of the dreaded dormammu the dark
dimension is a void within the marvel
universe an alternate plane of existence
described by some as hell itself it is a
place of bizarre dark energies from
which powerful ancient evils have arisen
other noteworthy residents of the dark
dimension include prince orini a
disciple of dormammu and umar an
extra-dimensional energy being born of
magic known as falteen umar is also
dormammu's twin sister though umar often
clashes with her brother and is
disdainful of his protege she and orini
were briefly bonded and clia is the
product of their union khalia's birth
however has ramifications for her mother
umar who is then trapped in her humanoid
form umar clashes with her brother after
being driven mad by her inability to
return to her true form and dormammu now
a powerful ruler banishes umar to a
pocket dimension despite all the
conflict in her family clea is raised
with no knowledge of her mother nor how
dormammu had exiled her from their home
reality clea is brought up to worship
her uncle the fire demon ruler of the
dark dimension and eventually becomes
one of his greatest admirers
growing up within the confines of the
dark dimension clia knew little about
what transpired beyond its borders
however all of that changes when dr
strange master of the mystic arts
arrives in her home dimension sent at
the behest of the ancient one strange is
there to confront cleo's uncle who has
designs on conquering earth clia is
fascinated by the magician and wants to
learn more about him and where he comes
from enamored she attempts to dissuade
strange from clashing with dormammu
knowing that the demon's wrath would not
spare him
[Music]
dormammu
i've come to bargain
after a battle between doctor strange
and dormammu clea is imprisoned by her
uncle for allying herself with the
earthbound sorcerer however when the
mindless ones a race of terrifying
demons are let loose in the dark
dimension doctor strange aids dormammu
in apprehending them to repay him
dormammu grants strange's request that
he set clia free following that first
encounter clea begins to aid doctor
strange in his many battles with
dormammu and each time she is punished
for her treachery however when dormammu
foolishly attempts to take down the
almighty cosmic being known as eternity
the two entities seemingly destroy each
other with dormammu gone strange is able
to free cleo once again although the
dark dimension found itself without a
king
unfortunately dormammu's supposed death
is not the end of clia's torment as umar
picks up right where her twin brother
leaves off once again clea finds herself
at the mercy of the dark dimension's new
ruler and doctor strange comes to her
rescue with counsel from the ancient one
strange realizes that cleo will never be
safe if she remains in her home reality
and arranges to remove her from the dark
dimension eventually clea joins strange
on earth and the extra-dimensional
sorceress moves to the big apple near
the sanctum sanctorum on bleecker street
however after her encounter with her
mother clea no longer has her incredible
powers on the earthly plane adjusting to
bodegas and riding the subway is bad
enough but adapting to life without her
abilities is an almost insurmountable
obstacle to help her acclimate to her
new home strange becomes her mentor and
teaches her the ways of the mystic arts
a common misconception about clea is
that she is simply a magician while she
is certainly a powerful sorcerer in her
own right clea is also half falten born
of the dark dimension this gives her
several natural abilities that
eventually return to her not the least
of which is the power of flight she can
also summon the flames of the falteen at
will a mystical energy source that
others such as doctor strange must use
magic to call forth however clea's
skills as a sorceress help enhance her
already considerable demonic abilities
and she is as capable with magic as
steven strange's this means that she too
can astrally project herself outside of
her body summon force shields produce
energy blasts and call down other
worldly weapons with a wave of her hands
clea is also a powerful magical telepath
who shares a unique connection
specifically with doctor strange as a
result of their close bond she has even
shown herself capable of implanting
false memories in others while being
able to read thoughts and detect
truthfulness of course her study of
magic also includes learning any number
of magic spells and incantations which
makes her like strange a sorceress with
a wide variety of abilities including
resurrecting the dead
i don't even want to know while they
start as master and apprentice the two
slowly form a bond that transcends that
relationship over time clia falls in
love with strange while steven clearly
holds some affection for her their
feelings are not equal at least not at
the start however strange's love for
clia eventually blossoms and the two
become a serious marvel power couple who
adventure together save the world
together and travel alternate realities
together since they are both sorcerers
their relationship goes beyond a
physical and emotional connection and is
nearly spiritual during their many years
together doctor strange and clea are
mystically bonded through vows that
could be considered a marriage in fact
while in her human form in new york clia
even wears a traditional human wedding
ring to signify her union with doctor
strange and jokes that it was the
commute that had made him hesitant to
commit unfortunately their blessed union
wouldn't last forever eventually
strange's womanizing came between them
with clea essentially asking for divorce
you might have a gift for the mystic
odds but you still have much to learn
as lovers dr strange and clea obviously
have a physical connection but they've
taken theirs a step further than most in
a key storyline stephen strange is
attacked by a villain called the silver
dagger after being stabbed strange finds
himself transported inside the eye of
agamotto and must find a way out at the
culmination of the story strange's
non-corporeal self escapes and discovers
that his protege and partner clea is
being tortured by silver dagger strange
learns that the villain sought the
powers of the sorcerer supreme and is
enraged when he discovers that strange
is not only the ancient one's newest
disciple but has recently taken up his
mantle with strange freed from the eye
of agamotto his soul inhabits the body
of none other than his protege and
partner clea and the two defeat the big
bad together though they quickly
separate sharing a body takes clea's
relationship with strange to a new level
when clea begins to feel that her love
for doctor strange isn't being
reciprocated she resigns her
apprenticeship at the same time clea
learns that the dark dimension is now in
the midst of an uprising against its
tyrannical ruler umar khalia's mother
returning to her home plane of reality
clia along with strange joins the
rebellion and helps dethrone umar it is
during this conflict that khalia finally
learns of her true parentage after clea
is victorious she exiles umar and her
father ahrini despite her misgivings
over strange's love she asks that the
sorcerer remain by her side as she takes
the throne of the dark dimension strange
declines and clia is left to rule alone
clia and strange have many future
encounters though as strange's nemesis
and clea's uncle dormammu fights to
regain his kingdom and the two team up
to defeat him time and time again
when the world's devouring being known
as galactus is sent into a magical realm
by a powerful sorcerer it leads to
cosmic calamity instead of remaining
trapped there galactus begins consuming
powerful beings from other dimensions
threatening to destroy any number of
different realms as he grows in power
doctor strange soon becomes galactus
herald while clea recruits her mother
umar to build a coalition of magical
forces to try and stop this dimensional
terror but it all leads to disaster and
before long doctor strange finds himself
with a little recourse but to go to the
devil mephisto for help striking a
twisted bargain dr strange offers up a
debt to be collected later if mephisto
will help them defeat galactus when all
is said and done doctor strange
successfully resets the universe and
reforms all of time and space as it was
before galactus threat emerged once the
dust is settled mephisto announces his
price clea's memories of doctor strange
tragically just before doctor strange
casts the spell that will wipe her
memory of him she tells him that she
thought they could finally be together
again
eventually clia's memories of dr strange
return but only through yet another
tragedy after being defeated by the
sorcerer cassilius every spell ever cast
by doctor strange is undone which allows
clea to regain her lost memories with
the help of a temporal remnant clea is
able to find stephen and resurrect him
to say goodbye once and for all however
doctor strange had one last surprise for
his true love gifting her the mantle of
sorcerer's supreme in his absence she
becomes a new and different kind of hero
wizard as well vowing to find a way of
resurrecting her ex-husband doctor
strange in honor of her lost love clea
takes the last name strange and received
her own new comic book title strange
which debuted in march 2022 perfectly
timed for her first mcu appearance in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
it may come as a surprise to fans of the
mcu but clea's appearance in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
where she debuts in a surprising
mid-credits scene is not her first time
appearing in live action though charlize
theron is sure to impress as the
sorceress when she returns to the mcu
cleo was played once before by actress
anne-marie martin in 1978's doctor
strange you'd be forgiven for not
knowing she made an appearance in the
film though as while she does share the
character's moniker she bears almost no
resemblance to her comic book
counterpart in the film martin plays
clea lake a young woman who inexplicably
shares a psychic bond with psychiatrist
stephen strange released from magical
imprisonment the villainous morgan
lafaye possesses lake's body as a way of
striking at strange's mentor thomas a
stand-in for the ancient one once left
leaves lake's body the young woman comes
under the care of strange which prompts
thomas to teach him the ways of the
mystic arts we have yet to see if clea
in the mcu will be a faithful
interpretation of the comic book version
but it can't be any further from the
source material than what we saw in the
1978 film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]